une production du studio sf mais nous
sans perdre le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on va nous éviter date cidj ph
quentin avec moi dôme plantes
si vous voulez enregistrer votre podcast
au studio sfr formule clé en main ou
est-ce que vous n'avez qu'à penser à
votre contenu ou est-ce qu'on s'occupe
du matériel et de la technique
ben c'est possible parce qu'on loue le
studio sf si vous voulez plus
d'information sur la location du studio
parce que vous avez un projet où vous
avez un podcast voulait amener à un next
vous n'avez qu'à écrire au sans fil
podcast at gmail.com
sinon cette semaine c'était un immense
plaisir de recevoir
l'auteur que j'adore david goudreault et
à juste avant qu on s'en parle un petit
peu plus au mollet remercie fourneaux
comme une star de disney le podcast
cette semaine et présenté par flip est
flippante peaks est une nouvelle
application qui se trouve être un réseau
social pour encourager les commerces
locaux vous le savez depuis les bleus
pandémie on a appris que le commerce
local c'est quelqu'un de fragile et
quelque chose qu'il fallait entretenir
faut l'encourager
c'est exactement la mission de flux pic
en fait comment ça se passe et que vous
vous abonnez souffler painting données
applications vous créer un compte et
ensuite peut partager tous vos coups de
coeur commerces locaux vous faites par
exemple moi je prends un petit café à
verdun je prends une photo jetable
commerce et tout le monde qui suit mon
compte sur full open pic peut découvrir
ce petit café local que je veux qu'on
encourage et vice versa si vous avez des
amis ou des proches des connaissances
même n'importe qui et que vous voulez
suivre des connaisseurs du commerce
locaux vous abonner à leur compte et
vous pouvez découvrir des nouveaux
commerces locaux par leur entremise
qu'est ce que ça nous donne de faire ce
dont on partage nos coups de coeur sur
l'épique on accumule des points
flip social passer pour un le bain c'est
pas le fun parce qu'on les échanges
qu'on en a assez cumulée contre des
offres exclusives donc ça peut être des
gratuités chez nos commerces locaux
justement pour découvrir encore plus de
commerces locaux on a un trait de promo
csf locale
donc vous inscrivez vous rentrez ses
codes promo l'oft avait déjà dit mille
points flip social coup du nil qui a
quinze mille avait déjà accès à des
offres exclusives
donc c'est super le fun pied encore une
fois sans courage de commerce local et
c'est super important qui est vrai
qu'elle est dans nos de l'application
commencer dès aujourd'hui à encourager
le commerce local
merci flip enrique le poteau 10e semaine
et présenté par nos amis chez pâli slip
moi je suis quelqu'un qui est allergique
d'en vivre de larges échos chats aux
chiens aux cochons à poussière mais
aussi aux acariens puis en ce moment
vous le savez c'est la saison des
allergies qui dit printemps dit ti nez
qui coule
on n'a pas besoin de s'ajouter à ceux
des allergiques sont pas nécessaires
d'un petit sucre dont matelots duranteau
de sa vie peut peser jusqu'à deux fois
son poids en bactéries dans ma carrière
je suis terrassé par ce fait mais c'est
des galaxies des pauvres hères cci 2 de
penser à ce que je sais pas si vous avez
déjà vu un acarien un mi temps par
microscope des photos de tuyaux la de ce
qu'elles donnent fait en ce moment le
fait que c'est dégueulasse dans ma
nature
qu'est ce que parler cela nous heurte
pour lutter conte seule la mousse avec
lesquels votre matelas effet et
antimicrobiennes donc fini
l'accumulation des microbes de bactéries
dans votre matelas puis en plus ça
prolonge considérablement la durée de
vie de mode de votre mac le donc ça vaut
vraiment la peine fun fact moi car
j'étais jeune ou si j'avais toujours le
nez bouché fait des tests d'allergie
allergique aux acariens à ce ça peut
nuire votre qualité de votre sommeil pis
selon n'y est pas avec ça c'est très
important en un code promo csf 25 pour
25 % de rabais
du 13 avril au 26 avril à leur fit vite
le sommeil c'est important alors on
s'est fait abattre le on s'achète un
oreiller let go tout à fait merci la
gagner
ouais fait que david goudreault super
belle conversation convient d'abord avec
david goudreault ne parlait de ses
oeuvres moi j'ai lu est la bête à samaa
et h
l'usap et son dernier un ta mort à mon
art à mort à moi deux romans qui sont
vraiment excellents le tout les deux
adorent y ont toujours trippé sur ben en
fait depuis que je connais cet auteur je
t'aime beaucoup sa lenteur que beaucoup
d'entre vous nous ont proposé aux six
déjà en fait c'est grâce à vous si on le
reçoit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui poète slameur vient de
lancer aussi un nouveau disque nouveau
ma dernière intérieur ok puis alors là
david goudreault vraiment réel plaisir
un énorme star était le jeune homme qui
qui parsèment les c'est son disco de
citations de grands auteurs
une réflexion super super évolué surtout
plein de sujets autant sur sur l'or sur
son art que sur notre société et qui
visiblement est réfléchie justement le
monde qui nous habite qu'on a des
tempêtes des fois il ya des invités
comme ceux qui sont vraiment faciles à
recevoir en podcast de david c'est
vraiment un excellent exemple parce que
on avait on avait une conversation qui
coulait vraiment vraiment très bien vous
allez voir si un moule en paroles
extraordinaire un homme de beaucoup de
mots mais de beaucoup de mots
extrêmement pertinent fait que on espère
que vous allez aimer la conversation
tant que nous si vous aimez la
conversation la meilleure chose que vous
pouvez faire en fait c'est partager le
podcast à vos amis de vive voix mais
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux ceci est
quelque chose qui est sous-estimé un
petit partage de sport f1 à valence en
story ça fait vraiment son bout de
chemin pour nous ça nous aide énormément
puis vous êtes de plus en plus coûteux
sans plus le podcast mais j'imagine que
c'est parce que je pense que vous aimez
surfer merci d'être là encore le podcast
pis bon écoute broadcast
[Musique]
yes david merci d'être le grand plaisir
merci messieurs même l'impression d'être
au parloir à bordeaux mais à part la vie
30 rené ouais ouais des comptes
actuellement il sait lire la fois qu'on
s'ennuie un peu le moins bon sens que ça
revient
3 il manque le stoppeur d'âge aussi je
pense concernant rex avec le printemps
qui arrive notre soif de terrain ces
deux rencontres
j'ai l'impression que ça va être de plus
en plus difficile d'être docile et de
bien respecter est résulté
conditionnement l'ailé les litres alors
voilà au pied de la lettre que je
cherchais est-ce que d'être créatif
pendant une pandémie comme ça bah ouais
enfin parle comme s'il y en avait
plusieurs
c'est comme si on avait plusieurs des
championnats d amy walsh et j'ai comme
pas le choix moi j'ai à cette espèce de
singe au paradise fière de ma
personnalité parce que quelqu'un plutôt
anxieux en fait de notre peau plutôt
champieux et je m'expose beaucoup en
fait c'est comme un mécanisme de défense
que j'ai développé pour gérer mon
anxiété ce ne jamais laisser a freiné
par ce don que je dis oui à tous les
projets qui me tente même si parfois
cela implique de m'exposer beaucoup de
me retrouver devant des foules ou peint
pas et je me retrouve donc avec une
belle pile deux contre et une belle main
boas bucket list de choses à vivre et à
faire dans mes vidanges toujours un peu
en action je je met des choses en place
pour m'arrêter par moments même
quelqu'un qui est beaucoup dans l'action
beaucoup exposé puis je lance des
projets donc quand j'ai du temps bonus
comme celui de la pandémie sur ma route
ben ça me permettra de mettre plus de
temps sur le dernier album de nouveau
matériel ça m'a permis d'aller au bout
d'un projet pour un livre jeunesse
ça m'a permis de faire plus de chronique
radio dans wii jeux créatifs puis de
toute façon moi je crois pas autant au
syndrome de la page blanche
la page belge par contre c'est un danger
la banque et à décrire j'écris je
pensais chuck close qui avait dit repris
d'ailleurs paref et des pelotes les
amateurs attendent l'inspiration les
écrivains écrivent par contre je
considère vraiment c'est un travail
store est un boulot puis parfois ben
faut forcer un peu pour ça marche bien
qu'auteur hemingway ou six qui disait à
celle d'écrire suffit de se mettre
devant dactylo il saignait à petit comme
une version à essence est ma préférée je
pensais richard brautigan peut être
qu'ils disaient pour moi écrire c'est
comme chier de la vitre personnes qui
souffrent et peut-être trop intense qui
souffrent décret mais d'efforts de
travail donc c'est cette idée d'attendre
spear à sion on s'intéresse souvent au
thé ou routine des gens créatifs ou
teddy les génies leur domaine sous des
grands compositeurs des grands écrivains
toi tu te trouvais justement tu as ta
manière de travail ta routine pour être
productif justement pourrait ou
absolument absolument pucheu j'encourage
tous ceux qui ont fait la création à
trouver parce que quand il ya plusieurs
éléments là dedans mais quand tu arrives
à avoir ton propre engrenage dont
propres mécanismes compréhension des
moments où tu es productif dans les
circonstances est tout sauf des heures
et des heures de travail
je pense la première chose c'est
vraiment découvrez son son rythme
circadien finalement c'est sa courbe de
productivité dans la journée et moins
volage sur le café encore fait douze ans
que j'ai pas consommer donc j'ai
découvert que je te productif
le matin ça a été piqué ni parce que je
me suis pas levé le matin pendant des
années a failli finir mais moi j'ai
découvert que plus je commence à écrire
taux plus efficace si je me mets à
écrire à 7 heures du matin
je peux écrire à 10 bonnes pages avant
midi puis ma journée est faite puis voir
je profite de la journée
si je commence à midi j'aurai de la
difficulté à créer cinq pages si je
commence à 6 en oublie surtout les
vidéos tchô devient intéressant page
d'index tout même des concerts non non
c'est le matin que ça se passe et un lot
tout travail que j'ai d'ailleurs sur moi
c'est même pas mis en scène c'est le
fameux dictaphone away est ce c'est
aussi un bel outil pour créer des
maladies parfois plus mais oui
conversation la wamu chanter ta femme
je note des idées mais qu'est ce que
c'est d'un autre
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] parce que c'est
tellement efficace que je le sors un peu
n'importe quand pour noter les idées je
rentre à peu près 150 à 200 entrées par
semaine d'art
donc je me mets un dimanche matin au
samedi matin je m'installe alors dit je
réécoute le dictaphone puis jour tous
mes dossiers romans poésies chansons un
projet plein pas puis c'est hyper
efficace parce que entre le moment où
j'ai une idée
on restera dans mon champ peu importe je
la note est le moment où je la réécoute
et je leur écris la france s'est placée
ou l'idée a pris le banc moi si j'ai
parfois juste dans le temps où je le dis
je le sais si c'est une bonne idée pour
elle mais des fois même ça change de
projets tjinder qui joue maintenant dans
un recueil des poètes allemands n'ont
que ça sonne jeu peut-être plus les
maintenant dans une chanson c'est
quelque chose de plus près de la réalité
donc pour moi c'est vraiment laid les
deux éléments je dirais de la création
dans mon corps sans vie et les plus
efficaces et ne perdre aucune idée en
les notant systématiquement et de me
lever tôt pour travailler tôt j'ai
seulement en plastique en verbalisant
une idée ça lui donne existence le tiers
fait pas je sais pas si dans ton esprit
puis que tu y penses activement ou non à
prend forme comme tu disais tu la phrase
se placer une belle façon de voir sur ce
trou à se place puis à prend pas de
place à 4 4 et une idée c'est de la
retenait est en train de mobiliser ton
esprit par la limite de capacité à avoir
de nouvelles idées
parce que il faut pas que j'oublie
sakifo d'ailleurs pour moi c'est le même
de m'arrêter parfois par exemple celle à
ma sauce et le pierrot parce que le jeu
peut fortement suivant le jeu la terre
qui obligeait que la salle est fini où
les rediffusions sentiment de vide
intense mais les voilà donc ça libère
aussi l'esprit parce que le nombre de
choses qui nous passe dans ta journée
quand il faut pas oublier la molina tout
donc après j'ai l'esprit on les oublie
tout le temps ce n'est pas tout le temps
mais j'imagine qu'elle fait que ça soit
un autre col dictaphone versus
l'application dictaphone sur un
téléphone est un choix conscient je me
dis c'est un choix conscient
premièrement parce que c'est plus rapide
kraft sur le très fort quand on
téléphone date à chercher l'appui bord
c'est peut-être une manipulation de
moins mais quand même de mouvements noël
voilà mais surtout en fait c'est que
j'ose espérer qu'un jour j'en fais basté
par la police selon l'auteur revient
tome nature je dois pouvoir énorme
baston
parce que c'est ça les femmes parce que
j'en ai beaucoup c'est quand même
beaucoup de route les conférences
espèrent en tout chemin sur l'autoroute
qui l'ont que probablement comment des
gens ferment c'est parce qu'on va passer
avec mes jeux c'est paul également fait
état des policiers les gars que je pense
qu'une espèce de truc dans l'oise qui
dit un appareil électronique qui fait
que je pense que je serais même pas
vous êtes en taule si jamais mon
dictaphone oui les pauvres c'est moins
dangereux aussi
je l'apprécié pas d'un pote tu reviens
j'ai pas le temps de voir les
notifications ces dangers aussi le temps
j'écoutais fait fi du bridge le tai chi
d'une chanteuse folk américaine de ti
qui dit justement t elle
quand l'inspiration le pire frère son
inspiration si son téléphone c'est
quelqu'un qui aimait tant qu'etat soit
pour écrire
si paul ouin ou seas mais a accru les
appliquer seul toutes les idées
créatives s'envolent plus rien exposé cd
machine géniale ces pillages jeu surtout
pas enfin le vieux réac lé allait le
téléphone ça a ruiné nos vies absolument
post un outil exceptionnel mais comme
n'importe quel outil un type conserverie
pour construire des coûts ou tels péter
dans le front comme un imbécile tu donc
on peut utiliser le téléphone de façon
ils parlent non productives mais ça peut
aussi être un super bon outil au niveau
des communications c'est assez facile et
tout mais c'est vrai que c'est bien fait
parce que il ya plein de réseaux sociaux
d'applications tu vont à capter son
attention qui vont être amenés devant de
garder son téléphone puis on peut
facilement perdre une heure et demie
deux en trois journées est de gagner là
dessus et d'où l'intérêt parfois aussi
quand on quand on écrit particulièrement
des romains parce que faut voir qu'un
rom as d'un méchant chantier temps
recueil de poésie c'est quand même
beaucoup de travail aussi meilleur parti
qui mijote plus que témoin dans
l'écriture et écriture correction un
roman pour que 300 pages qui se tiennent
ces des milliers dans le travail puis
tout ce qu'ils vont couper ton est là
ton souffle va se ressentir d'une façon
ou d'une autre
moi je pense que plus tu arrives à
sortir à accoucher ton histoire on rame
a rapidement plus ça va se tenir
vous savez pas dit que ça ferait un
mauvais ramasse-tout létale dans le
temps
mais quand même une question de souffle
qu'ils montrent par exemple avec la
trilogie de la bête c'est un défi
littéraire de faire trois romans 3-1
donc sorti le premier ça m'apprend
abondamment merci je pense que ce papa
lé la qualité on parle de laquelle type
luthor que j'ai adoré mais met des gros
à main d oeuvre quand même assez
volumineuse cependant sortir une parade
exerce à 20,7 s'inquiète pages en tout
donc ça a été un vrai défi
mais paradoxalement j'ai l'impression
que la qualité justement de de
l'ensemble réside beaucoup sur le fait
que je ne suis pas arrêter quelqu'un
j'ai terminé le monde est rapidement
j'ai embarqué dans le deuxième sa
savante et puis à chaque fois c'était un
peu en ligne c'est à dire que j'avais
pas prévu même à la base farine trilogie
quand le sortie promis le premier sorti
bon maintenant il faut dans le vent n'a
qu'à le premier sorti la réaction était
bien plus grande que celle que
j'espérais que mon éditeur je pense ou
ce espérait donc qui avait une demande
je me suis dit baye a une fin ouverte
est ce que je fais une suite temps 48
chauffant trilogie mais je progresse et
épargner que ce personnage le pana
disait oui je le fais trois ans 3 ans et
est finalement ben ça m'a permis aussi
d'avoir cette espèce de souffle à chaque
fois d'heure qui germait tout dans sa
sans prévoir la fin cet ancien agent de
cacher vos troisième du bon boulot les
deux premiers marchés faut que le
troisième se tiennent mais vous
comprenez l'idée c'est de toujours
garder cette espèce d'intensité dans
l'écriture et pendant ces deux années là
j'ai pas eu beaucoup de temps à perdre
justement me laisser distraire de
rattrapage après sur des séries venez de
parler pendant que créatif entendu
parler de game of thrones tous à quel
point je me suis fait avoir
quel final de la non mais je sais c'est
là si les résultats directs
de la culture du block buster hippie du
décoder coûte le début il voulait sortir
une heure une oeuvre magistrale pour fin
mai puis en même temps ça donne raison
que je prêche pour ma paroisse mais ça
donne raison à la fameuse phrase que la
série où le film sera jamais aussi bon
que le livre parce qu'ils y ont voulu
finir la série à l'an qué l'évitement et
voilà comme monsieur martin n'avait pas
fini la ctq pauillac chili dans les
conneries partout dans le monde
mais peut-être avec un peu de patience
la fin voilà bien ce qu il paraît qu'un
paquet d'anjou aussi le haut niveau
devaient travailler sur un autre projet
et puis on a un peu bousculé le truc
même aux bourses
pour moi ça c'est inacceptable d'aller
jouer dans taille de quelqu'un que ce
soit à travers une c'est un film un
livre est arrivé avec une fin aussi la
boîte chirac c'est vraiment le bon terme
à dire devrait couper la main de tout
les autant qu'ils finissent par ce
n'était qu'un rêve assez bien fait
aucune espèce d'ambiguïté forces
américaines très coquine dans les
finales comme ça mais qui s'est amené ya
un doute mais mais ces seuils
il ya quelques pauvres est bon je pense
que les les créateurs ont une
responsabilité envers le public d'offrir
une finale qui soutient que non non pour
moi c'est primordial
les gens investissent tellement temps
puis d'énergie et d'émotion dans ton
truc que tu peux pas de temps dans la
ville et - enfin exact c'est trop facile
de lancer des intrigues des ficelles se
rattache rien tu peux laisser des trucs
un peu dans l'ambivalence souvent il
faut que tu étais d une chute faut qu'il
se passe quelque chose
justement parlant des deux films tournés
en libye parlant des finales j'ai fini
la bête à sa mère ce matin-là
traumatisme non ça vous rassure mais
j'étais petite demi heure
à meylan que l'hymne est intervenue qui
justement à la fin le personnage est
dangereux c'est de le dire de façon à
parabolique
non mais je veux le dire et puis si tu
me dis que sans spoiler on le coprah
braking mais le personnage dit j'espère
que je suis vraiment très mal me dit
quelque chose comme dit pas qu'on fera
un film quelque chose avec mon histoire
est ce que ça c'est david goudreault qui
lança dans l'univers de rien ça va en
fait
est-ce que je lançais dans les niveaux
au moment où je les écris non pour et
honnêtement je pensais la balle est
allée rejoindre un jeune public jeune
adulte qui tripent sur les trucs un peu
trash mais je pensais pas que ça allait
saleh avant un si grand retentissement
puis le ca va être adapté dans quelques
semaines noté entre autres i dans
l'hérault depuis des gens qui
travaillent sur ce temps développement
aussi pour la télé donc ça va au delà de
mes espérances mais j'ai l'impression
quand même que tous les les écrivains
espère que d'une façon ou d'une autre
leurs oeuvres volées dépassé voire
raisonner autrement c'est pas une
question d'ego c'est juste une question
le désir d'arriver quelque chose d'assez
fort de ses origines alou assez en phase
avec son temps pour que d'autres
personnes aient envie de se l'approprier
une belle appropriation même pour le
temps dont j'ai rien eu à voir avec le
texte puis pour la série télé je suis un
consultant à peine je voulais pouvoir
l'éliminer dans le cambouis je préfère
que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre
qu'il fasse que celle l'approprient mais
peut-être que oui à travers mon
personnage tellement désir que
j'exprimais ça non seulement via tamara
- mon dernier roman aussi des jeux
quelqu'un qui aime une option pour les
droits puis c'est génial de dsd ok c'est
une matière très bien que j'ai créée
finalement ni pour servir à autre chose
d'un point de vue artistique qui peut
amener un outil de création
enfin pendant
au mieux tant mieux puis peut-être que
je dis bien des choses à travailler mais
personne ne sait pas trop toi parce
qu'il très antipathique
c'est patricia paquin exact quand même
je pense que tous les auteurs se
retrouve un peu à travers le personnage
la bête je dirais que c'est plutôt mon
antithèse ces mêmes je considérais
mousse et des rames engagés dans la
mesure où whiston un criminel tout
croche c'est un il comptait y est à ma
famille d'origine est fédéraliste il ya
tous les défauts c'est france justement
tout ce qu'il dit d'inacceptable je
pense le contraste espèce de
dénonciation sepang l'application de
cette crise analysé commerçante qui
valait son pesant war j'ai tort d'être
un pas bon come stay gold bien trouvé
d'armes entre donc une espèce de deux
côtés voilà le le le reflet négative la
chose mais en même temps comme j'ai mis
en exergue du roman son dicton que
j'aime beaucoup qui dit même une horloge
castrés donne l'heure juste deux fois
par jour et moi je pense que les
légendes en la marge les gens carrément
brisé les personnes qui ont des des
grandes difficultés ce que le g coûts
vont quand même donner l'heure juste
parfois ils vont nous renvoyer une
vision qui est non seulement vallée
légitime et qu'il faut écouter
il ya quelque chose de douloureux dans
la dépression dans les épisodes
dépressifs mais aussi de lucidité dans
la dépression d'ailleurs j'ai créé
quelque part que la lucidité la première
cause de dépression dans parfois cette
espèce de regard très crue très dur sur
la vie il faut l'accueillir aussi puis
c'est correct qui est de la littérature
dans les audiences de la guimauve pire
tout ce pick up la joie mais il y aussi
beaucoup de gens qui souffrent
profondément pic doivent être
représentés dans notre culture dans
notre littérature il faut les entendre
faut les voir ces gens là aussi on se
trouve à voir ce qu'ils en pensent quoi
avoir de l'empathie pour soir je le
trampoline parce qu'on voit le monde à
travers ses yeux plan comprend
en connaissant son histoire qu'est ce
qui l'a amené qu'est-ce que pousser à
être da manière qu'il est natif et que
finalement ça ça nous fait avoir un
regard peut-être justement tu es plus
empathique envers des gens qu'on
comprendrait pas nos comportements sont
savait pas d'où il est tout compris
notre compris c'est vraiment le le le je
dirais l'essence du roman c'est un peu
d'humaniser les monstres et non pas de
justifier les comportements mais il ya
personne qui n'ait adressé à une
personne qui ne tuent à on peut avoir
des prédispositions génétiques c'est sur
un même jeu trop se fascine à clé les
bébés ont des personnalités quelque
chose d'intense mais au delà de son
bagage génétique et sa personnalité de
base on est construit puis on est
détruit en cours de route dans nos vies
et souvent les lits grand atteignable
violent qu'on va avoir un risotto envers
soi-même prennent leurs racines dans
notre histoire personnelle et quand on
connaît ce canton c'est ce que quelqu'un
vécu en amont de sa crise
ben ça lui m'a mise beaucoup et puis moi
comme travailleur social parce que c'est
d'abord ça ma formation
j'en ai vu des situations ou sms a aucun
sens et montreux ou même comment tu peux
te mène damas comme ceux où déjà pris
dans dépendance ou dans les
comportements super destructeur pitt
tous envie de le braz
mais c'est pas si simple
je peux pourtant tu entends sortie juste
comme ça hop spawn question qu'au pied
dans le cul piteux on pourrait partir
sur toute la question de la santé
mentale mais on est des êtres très
complexe les humains puis une fois qu'on
aura pris certains mauvais pli c'est
très difficile de s'en sortir et mon
personnage de livre en livre c'est un
peu cette espèce de dena la non
résilience puis qu'est ce qui se passe
quand tu prends toujours la mauvaise
décision piqué tu te retrouves très très
loin finalement d'ardentes et déviances
sur cette question là la question
d'aider des humains qu on marginalise
mettons dans notre société par leur part
leurs troubles de santé mentale mais ton
jeu tentant des dents
une conversation avec williams et
gouailleur sur le podcast association
libre je pense qu'ils s'appellent puis
c'est vraiment une superbe conversation
puis termine une tournure de phrase que
j'ai vraiment qui est vraiment raisonnée
puis je pense que la conversation était
au tour de de priver ces gens là d'avoir
accès aux eaux contact humain dans la
société puis tout viré sur l'autre bord
en disant non c'est plutôt la société
qui se privent de ces gens là tu parles
par leur unicité puisqu'ils ont apporté
à la conception qu'on a de la vie pic
qu'au final ce site une conception
différente du milieu dans lequel tu
essaies punt c'est pas ça veut pas dire
que c'est pas aussi valable fait que
cette vision là je trouve que c'est
super un très simple de pouvoir
l'aborder puis la sortie quand tu
rencontres des gens qui ont clairement
des troubles de santé mentale ou qu'on
clairement pas qu'ils répondent pas aux
standards qu'on se fait maintenant c'est
absolument c'est très vrai skate à mendy
de l'autre côté je pensais toute la
question de se priver des fous du
village moins l'impression qu'on a moins
de foot du village alors que c'était une
méchante belle épée savoir la ville ou
d'un village ccc phu lôc gens qui
pensent autrement puis j'aime l'image te
dit la personne qui est différente comme
le pot sur une montée le pot c'est celui
qui le plus différent de la gagne moins
mais c'est lui qui permet de saisir n'y
a pas de poussée saisie - et puis à
vouloir tout être pareil puis on perd
quelque chose et au surtout s'éclate
détresse des autres nous fait peur
souvent que ça va être un espèce de mur
ou au 11 bloqués et parfois quand on
prend le temps de regarder derrière ça
on a accès à des histoires incroyables à
des humains parfois même très résilient
malgré leur des chances malgré leur
détresse dans cette détresse là ils
survivent après quinze ans aspic et à
l'erreur y en a tous les jours
la personne est encore debout sur le
coin de la rue
été mais qu'est ce qu'une forme de
résilience lendemain mais c'est pas
encore suicider puis encore un potentiel
pour cette personne-là de s'épanouir
peut-être que pour elle c'est pas
nourrir c'est pas avoir bungalow à
sainte-thérèse avec deux enfants et demi
puis un champ dans l'entrée mais ça va
peut-être de décrire un beau poème dans
un atelier de création que l'itinéraire
ça va peut-être être de jeu s'arrêtait
de consommer ou consommer moins ça va
était de renouer avec un ami ou d'aller
réparer quelque chose à travers une
thérapie mais là il faut pas justement
s'éloigner ou éloigner ces gens là parce
que souvent c'est des histoires fort
intéressante exil leçon dedans il faut
vent au dessus de la détresse puis
écoute anecdotes lama particulier mais
ce matin je me suis arrêté avant
d'arriver si je te prends d'avancement
la caf répit jusqu'à la rue un enfant
qui manifestement probablement un prop
soins bouffées délirantes quimperlé de
ce coin de la rue entre les entrées les
épisodes de cadres que choisir auprès
des voitures puis à premier abord moi
même travailleur social qui a oeuvré en
santé mentale comme ça parce qu'il est
intense dans son approche mais en
restant le par la voyant les remet en
doute ses mérites seul vient à parler
avec elle même ou à quelqu'un que moi je
pouvais pas voir
puis je voyais qu'elle lève un beau
sauver qui avait quand même dit moi-même
et datée elle avait comme une espèce de
côté très lumineux très très vivant puis
à la limite je me débats à mettre la vie
dans le quartier c'est sûrement qu'à
minuit deux heures du mat rsa douga cet
intégrisme mais sinon haddad matin côté
des grands éclats de voix permettait de
la vie dans ce quartier là où il n'y
avait pas d'enfants il se passait rien
donc
wally fou du village faux faux l'égard
des prêts nous faut leur faire une place
puis il marquait elles marquent leur
milieu sherbrooke on avait madame book
était un classique qui nous faisait
faire le saut à tous et coin de rue
trois-rivières rose la petite madame
argent tu as eu qui est qui est décédée
n'est pas si longtemps ça ça m'a touché
le tas eu qui se promenait avec son
espèce de gros tricks plainte à utah usa
l'ue et tellement système souris dans
journée mais là les 200 à 300 fois que
j'ai vu ta urbain ces deux à trois cents
fois où j'ai une spa s'attendrit pour 1
go qui pourrait pas travailler qui
peut-être pas dans une démarche de
dépassement de soi au quotidien mais
qu'est ce qu'un beau saurait et puis qui
est différent qui amène quelque chose
d'autre d'avis voilà sa couleur faut pas
mettre de côté car ça me fait passer
quelque chose que j'ai pas pensé depuis
toujours le métier quand j'étais petit
on n'était pas un ami dans la rue type
ont choisi tout temps dans la rue
revenant de l'école vers 4h ses vingt
trois quatre heures ont joué en jeunes
en ruby avait là patrick qui passe et
patrick c'était 1 à 1 go et et yvette
vingtaine trentaine c'est un handicapé
mental c'est qu'ils habitent encore chez
ses parents plus beau dans la rue qui
pensaient tout en mémoire du revenu de
chez paou le ti et oscar est dangereux
puis passer leur sa petite boîte à
nantes puis le ton avait sept huit neuf
entrées puis patrick head on et jean zay
à chaque fois un salut patrick il
s'arrêtait une chose un peu et continuer
sa route et puis on parlait en parler
avec lui de seppi
tu es un agent un peu d'un peu nouveau
type i on aimait se parler avec mes
petits hôtes et on se moque un peu loose
et parce qu'on était des jeunes du 10
août
mais amman et patrick qui arrêtaient pas
aux sites et aux pauvres quoi expliquer
ce qui s'est passé mais patrick a été
passée du crémant s'est ennuyé patrick
away cia téléphone puisse amener quelque
chose de différent qui a mené au filet
tout le temps de bonne humeur tout le
temps faim tout le temps bien me patrick
est sûrement vous lui appartient aussi
tout dépendra du niveau bac
dans les mets mais je convaincu que cela
va lui apporter quelque chose au site
c'était à la limite c'est justement la
question qu'on peut se poser est qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui est important au final
impies l'humain est un animal social
on a besoin de se définir à travers les
eaux dans le regard de l'autre malgré
tout on a besoin de créer du lien et ces
personnes là ça nous ramène je pense au
dénominateur commun il ya une espèce de
grande soif d'affection de
reconnaissance moi je suis fana des
trisomiques à chaque fois que j'ai eu
l'occasion de passer du temps avec eux
c'est des humains est merveilleux il dit
qu'ils sont vraiment dans la spontanéité
elle est quelque chose de l'enfance qui
qui qui survit en rugby
des fois ça ramène à l'essentiel c'est
comme moquette entraîne des demi tours
10 avec mes 45 projets qui est qui et
paniers dans des mails et des conflits
prenant des relations soient finalement
qu'est ce qui me reste à la fin puis
qu'est ce qui est important
cette personne là peut-être le comprend
mieux que moitié à 30,1 vouloir donner
des bisous à sa main puis à se coller
sur ressenti franc puis s'en foutent
d'avoir une carrière et la
reconnaissance sociale et dessous c'est
dans l'instant présent c'est ici
maintenant
les enfants aussi ont ce que puis et
puis moi c'est mon meilleur enracinement
au monde en ce moment et j'ai une grande
de 6 ans parce que quatre en pis les
deux sont tellement dans l'instant
présent quelques mots ça me ramène je
peux virer fou le tout dans le
ressentiment de la colonne je peux je
peux fly et nos temples y ait eu des
bombes humaines crise et croyable
chenneviette jeu le plus joué avec toi
presque un froid intense et et consoles
ok or pas bien on joue et je veux sommes
aux dames et bim est capable de passer
le déclare chez aussi vite que ce nom
mouche j'ai toujours dormi mais en
priorité dans les enjeux et à ta table
et on se fait des scénarios pour
n'imagine alors que l'instant présent
basset lopy ces personnes love
finalement qu'on voit peu ou pas que ce
soit des gens qui ont des troubles de
santé mentale des troubles cognitifs des
troubles envahissants du développement
ou tout simplement des enfants unis
peuvent n'avoir aucun trop mais qui sont
encore très connectée à 7 dès l'instant
présent de les motifs de la relation
puis finalement je pense est ce c'est
l'essentiel cesse un peu cliché de la
dîme et c'est pour cette façon ça a été
dédiée à toutes les époques ce souhait
carpediem yolo peu importe mais c'est
quand même qu'est ce qui s'passe l'eau
c'est là dessus que du pouvoir passer ce
qui construit puis essaie de rester là
si on le dit de façon un peu plus
hardcore j'ai un ami m a amené qui à
côté on est dans les regrets du passé ou
dans les appréhensions pour l'amener
êtes si quand un pied dans le passé puis
un pied dans l'avenir était bien placé
pour chier sur ton présent j'allais pas
[Rires]
prié la voilà il faut sera menacée ce
qui nous reste à faire
1 quand tu dis que tu étais des cas de
partir c'est loin dans le temps les les
conflits pile jeu mais les idées noires
et de deux amis de de ressentiment
envers une situation une personne est ce
que pour toi l'écriture ça a été un
moyen de d'évacuer ce rapidement dans ta
vie ou mal écriture pour moi c'est assez
l'outil qui sera un atout le sait
vraiment autun mais un côté très ludique
des jardins créés je pense qu'ils rien
qu'ils m'apportent autant de
satisfaction que de trouver la bonne
france de la france le chercher pour
l'aller les punchline
je ressens pas un parti mais ça c'est
vraiment une satisfaction profonde et
aussi de l'ird pour moi la littérature
aux auteurs d'écrits que de lire pièce
autour de ma vie puis quand je tombe sur
une phrase dans laquelle je me reconnais
ou que j'aurais voulu écrire les quelque
chose de vraiment satisfaisant lendemain
mais au niveau du jeu je sais pas quel
point c'était un petit c'est sûr que que
seul et en partie mais ça peut pas tout
guérir non plus ça peut pas tout traiter
de nos difficultés mais il ya clairement
pour moi plusieurs fonctions à
l'écriture oui bah premièrement ça
permet de gagner ma vie puis de nourrir
mes enfants ce qui pose qui propose un
travail
l'écriture est quand même aucun de ma
vie professionnelle mais c'est aussi non
seulement une source de plaisir oui
probablement quelque chose qui me permet
de prendre conscience
peut-être que ça travaille la poésie
j'ai l'impression pour moi les romans
c'est plus mon terrain de jeu où le vrai
manche dans le délai dans fiction puis
j'essaie de faire réagir
le lecteur ou la lectrice alors que en
poésie je suis plus viscéral c'est plus
comme vraiment ce que je ressens puis à
ce moment alors effectivement je vais
probablement être davantage de soigner
quelques jours ce traité quelque chose
d'un autre côté je pense pas qu'on
change tant que ce temps on apprend à
vivre avec soi puis on arrive à agen et
certains des fautes je pense qu'on peut
apporter quelques gros changement c'est
comme moi par rapport à la consommation
par un gros problème puis c'est l'espèce
de côté obsessif compulsif qui est
encore là donc le comportement de
consommer ça a été le plus gros
changement que j'ai apporté dans ma vie
puis plein de conséquences positives
mais ce qui m'a mené à consommer c'est
encore le laisser les besoins des tacite
et l'absolue pee wee une espèce de
pulsion autodestructrice aussi des
d'aller chercher une intensité toujours
un plus grand empire ben tiens danger là
pour moi qui va toujours être là de
toute façon pris cette espèce de deux
côtés de ressasser le passé ben ça m'a
servi aussi parce que le fait d'être
très dans ma tête et dans mes scénarios
une côte
j'en ai fait un travail très gelé great
donc je renie pas cette facette lot de
moi mais je sais pas quel point
l'écriture l'homme soigné via quelques
pages apprend plutôt à être en paix avec
8,6 comme il ya des facettes de ma
personnalité qui me gausse puis j'essaie
de menuiser leur impact dans ma vie au
quotidien mais probablement que ça va
être encore là dans 21 dans 40 1 mais je
dirais les lébous les plus destructeurs
j'ai réussi à enlever sont donc déjà pas
mal mais en lisant la base justement
tiges en connaissez beaucoup moins sur
toi que que maintenant mais tant pis
justement artiste un personnage c'est
avec une enfance pas difficile qui est
passé de familles d'accueil famille
d'accueil puis on tracte décrivent une
réalité puis j'ai l'impression que c'est
une réalité que tu te connaissais le
tipi jeu mais demain je me disais
comment qui
comment c'est rigolo que je connais pas
vraiment mais que georges laraque ya pas
de l'anti de son personnage dira c'est
vrai que ça commence quand c'est au top
la presse j'ai su que tu cites avait eu
est avait travaillé comme travailleur
social se fait que j'ai dit ce genre de
personnes là ce genre de milieu ils
l'ont côtoyé je n'avais pas non plus
aussi que tu avais eu un problème de
dépendance problèmes des autres
destructeur que ton personnage hunt et
puis finalement ce personnage là c'est
qu'ils ont un peu la version de toi que
tu aurais pu devenir dans le bosquet
scénario le pire de ce que j'aurais pu
être dans certains cas puis d'un autre
côté moi je revendique le droit à la
fiction télé au québec puis en
littérature occidentale de façon plus
large on est beaucoup dans l'auto
fiction des prêts près du racing se met
moi je crois encore à la fiction points
et fiction je pense qu'on peut se
décoller nos personnages puis vraiment
se mettre dans la peau des hopis créé
dans wii on part très inspiré une part
des fictions aussi dans tamara - on
n'est déjà plus dans la fiction mais
j'ai l'impression que il y aussi une
recherche qui était faite de façon plus
ou moins consciente c'est à dire que ça
m'intéresse tout répit le lien à la
criminalité le lien est la détresse
psychologique
ce sans nécessairement avoir tout vécu
ce c1 ça m'intéresse j'ai beaucoup lu là
dessus et j'ai fait des recherches
je raconte une anecdote un des plus
beaux en fait de deux anecdotes qui a
conquis son prochain les plus beau
compliment qu'on ait pu me faire comme
comme romancier après la sortie du
deuxième temple à l'abattée saccage qui
se passe en prison dans la connaît c'est
vraiment un huit clos carcéral
je faisais des tournées d'automne
conférences et tout peut m'emmener je me
retrouve dans un centre notamment real
nord puis une vingtaine de personnes
pensent qu'ils ont le les fondus cuts au
pied dans la salle jeune femme qui étend
un peu plus retirés trépied vraiment du
véhicule en face le tout au caire et
cotait pas son premier barbecue
on était à son barbecue de détresse mais
ces joueurs qui est vraiment intense à
skis à vie par leurs poteaux d'accord la
limite c'est intimidant
puis à la fin bon les gens viennent me
voir dédicaces les livres parlent un peu
plus belles arrive juste à la fenêtre
puis j'ai parlé un peu de mon parcours
pendant la conférence pm10 la branche
maladie devant - didot jamais fait de
temps non je ne vais pas faire de prison
a dit lahm dit écoute sa méthode en
tabarnak - charles dana chars de
joliette est un juif est certain puis à
les faire dans ce passé ton livre puis
honda tout convaincu tf1 du temps parce
que la maniaque que tu le décris
c'est ça la réalité en herbe et ça c'est
le plus beau compliment qu'on puisse
mois puis avec eux c'était cette
femme-là qui gêne ce que sa maman
contacter qu'une bénévole à joliette et
finalement j'ai pu aller rencontrer les
filles qui ont un club de lecture à
présent des femmes à joliette c'est
génial et les femmes sont impliqués là
dessus d'ailleurs une écrivaine qui est
qui et lucky qui m'a fait lire son
manuscrit est vraiment un bon potentiel
puis les filles est en droit de recevoir
un autant par année les 1 livre par mois
ils peuvent rencontrer longtemps par
avions choisi père cette année le ch
j'y suis à l'écouté au moment de grâce
incroyable simplifieront et échecs et
par parent montlivault aussi pu en
extraire connaissez d'un côté impulsif
la consommation avec s'inquiéter ça leur
faisait penser à lens en fin de
rencontre a été un dragon exceptionnels
mais en fait que ça m'a dit c'est que
j'avais bien fait mon travail de
recherche parce que c'était réaliste ça
reste un roman ça reste la fiction mais
un bon roman
c'est une espèce d'équilibré entre le
délai créatif de fiction et une
vraisemblance il garde un ancrage dans
le réel et par rapport à ce qu'on a en
particulier je pensais que celle là est
le plus beau compliment qu'on peut faire
à ce moment j'ai dit non
encore plus encore plus intense je vais
rencontrer les gars d'annacone faire un
atelier de création à l'ao au fédéral à
donnacona et à quand j'arrive là la
preuve qui m'accueille à des écoutes ont
un petit malaise
on a fait lire là bas tu as a man games
day ont vraiment repris on succède
trilogie voulait absolument lire le
deuxième mais le troisième on ne peut
plus la donne est troisième mais la
direction refuse et moins et s attend à
ce que ça se passe à donnacona et il
trouvait que c'était trop réaliste et
c'était la première fois que je mettais
les pieds dans cette prison le samedi
que de l'extérieur avec les recherches
que j'avais fait les infos que j'avais
eu des agents correctionnels des détenus
et qui jasaient j'ai quand même réussi à
toucher suffisamment la réalité de cette
prison leur pour que la direction refuse
que le livre soit midem indigo et ce qui
est très drôle c'est que j'en avais
apporté
est ce que j'ai fait pour vrai c'est que
j'ai fait serrer les lego est guidé par
son délire en erreur des moments joué
pascal mary us met les tripes ça tard et
j'ai fait tirer la version de la bête et
saccages et legault qui le gagne et ça a
été mis dans ses affaires personnelles
fakaté va sortir et voir avancer ces
jeans sont les paquets de cigarettes et
la bête et ça casse et c'est vraiment
c'est sûr et l'on devrait comme maman ce
v6 toujours exception parce que c'est un
milieu qui tellement pas naturel de la
prison avoir des gens qui ont invité
incroyables qui ont soif de liberté sous
un croyant et une autre gagne qui sont
les agents correctionnels ont des amis
agents correctionnels qui marque qui me
raconte des histoires aussi entre autres
tout petit c'est vraiment deux gagne qui
se rencontrent lots tn etc sont payés
pour pour surveiller plus haute
ils sont à temps plein à penser que
niaiseries parfum quand elles peuvent
consommer comme ils peuvent sortir de
deux le temps du débat de l'extérieur
dans cette partie d'échecs constante
ça peut être assez as un temps assez
particulier c'est si incroyable qu'on
pousse ces détenus le à découvrir
justement lors la lecture n'est pas
parce qu'ils connaissaient déjà mythique
on encourage
cette phase est l'oeuf certains jeux
mais en fait les recherches qui te fais
mais je suis certain que ça doit sauver
une coupe pareille tient ce contact là
si je sais d'avoir une méchante gang qui
ont jamais écrite poèmes puis encore
moins livrés soit dans un groupe de
personnes type idée d'avoir ce contact
là avec la beauté y avait quelque chose
de plus grand que la réalité des
barreaux de la prison nécessairement
quelque chose de fort je suis certain
que ça donne un pack ultra possessif
ouais ben oui puis en fait j'ai envie de
remonter sur les termes que tu utilises
et d'avoir contacté que la beauté la
beauté que laquelle sont en contact
c'est leur propre esprit c'est le capes
de création disent que c'est pas moi
c'est même pas moi comme tsmc pour moi
comme prêtre qui vaut comment gérer la
leur leurs maîtres ce 1e et lampes mon
chien comme un peu un agent facilitateur
pour leur donner accès puis ce qu'ils
disent qu'ils révélaient c'est eux c'est
ce qui leur appartient puis sur l'un des
coaches demain un talent et parfois ça
peut être super profond puis j'ai vu des
gars les larmes aux yeux puis parfois ça
peut être juste drôle c'est un ex fondé
des textes la bouffe la cafétéria ou
quand arrive on s'évade ipsca lundi il
se découvre quand même à un talent
souvent pour l'écriture parce que c'est
un côté moins que auquel je tiens de
rendre la littérature accessible chez
que ça peut déranger parfois les
puristes et tout mais moi je pense que
c'est fait pour tout le monde c'est bon
pour tout le monde dit que la plupart
des gens connaissent la littérature plus
qu'elle ne le pense puis utilise des
expressions à extraire des des livres il
faut des grands classiques les deux volt
hadopi 4 soit fait prendre conscience
qu'ils regardaient déjà de la poésie
dans ta vie à travers les expressions
d'utiliser des jo est de la littérature
dans ton quotidien que t'es pas obligé
de lire un texte de 500 pages pour être
en contact avec la littérature s'il
trouve un poème que tu aimes le
prends le intègre le pis tu vas voir la
littérature en toi ça va influencer ton
écriture ton style puis tu vois tu vois
apparaître à ta manière éventuellement
travers ça donc c'est effectivement de
faire émerger la beauté chez à celle
détenue mais ici c'est beaucoup que les
ados puis dans des organismes
communautaires puis on le voit peu ce
lieu quand même quelques reportages moi
j'ai des projets aussi pour faire
rayonner c'est un peu mais il y en a
plusieurs et au québec en ce moment
qu'ils ont cette vocation l'autre il ya
plusieurs prêtres qui vont dans les
écoles où sont écrits - plusieurs
rapports aussi à racheter avec sans
pression puis il me racontait que lui il
faut aussi l'un des écoles pour écrire
je rappe indiquent-ils côté c'est
exceptionnel avoir accès à sauver mon
pote et manu militari aussi créé des
conférences et sopi pour moi c'est
d'aider des paillettes avec beaucoup de
talents puis des slameuse aussi qui vont
dans les écoles donc peu importe l'angle
comprend que ce soit par le rap le slam
la poésie directement la littérature
mais mettre en contact avec ça ça peut
être le moment effectivement qui va
faire basculer un jeune dans un désir de
création
ça peut changer sa vie mais c'est aussi
un moment de de prise de conscience qui
est quelque chose qui s'appelle la
littérature québécoise est plus grand
que la somme de tous ces auteurs s'est
porté par des générations à travers une
histoire littéraire importante et que
c'est au coeur de notre identité au camp
de notre culture ce que man est
important de défendre notre langue notre
culture d'effets en quoi ces subtilités
ce exact qu'est ce que tu veux le testu
tim hortons bilingue où c'est qu'il est
les grands poètes les grands écrivains
donc ça fait aussi partie de qui on est
et juste d'aller piquer la curiosité
là-dessus ouvrir une porte
je pense ça peut faire la différence
parce que les sportifs des écoles
publiques afin dé pouce mettre la main
devant la bouche des microbes tiers
parti laisse partir dans les écoles sont
hyper reconnu il pas valorisé c'est
correct
ces banques grecques sont pas en train
de dire qu'il en faut moins mais je dis
qu'il faut aller à côté ce avec la
science et la culture
moi j'en ai fait des centaines d'écoles
au québec le débogueur soviétique j'en
ai vu un cure-dent longtemps mais quand
je rentre dans l'école en moins de cinq
minutes je peux dire c'est quoi le nom
l'équipe sportive dans quoi ils sont
bons gc qui les professionnels qui ont
une bagnole ils sont passés par cette
école
exact mais c'est qu'ils vont gêner en
herbe c'est qu'ils vous écrivain
s'équivaut artistes il ya des écoles qui
les met en valeur puis bravo mais je
pense que ça devrait être généralisé de
façon plus grand et qu'on devrait avoir
un budget équivalent parce que le budget
sport dans certaines écoles c'est
vraiment impressionnant je n'ai pas
d'école qui ont l'équivalent au niveau
artistique qui vont mettre autant
d'argent l'argent qui met pour faire un
terrain de football et acheter de
l'équipement
si tu mettais ce pour avoir des livres
neufs dans ta bibliothèque faire venir
des écrivains des écrivains tu
changerais la vie des jeunes artistes et
scientifiques parce qu'il faudrait faire
la même chose au niveau scientifique de
façon il pas significatives et
ultimement c'est plate à dire mais dans
ta gang de jeunes sportifs qui trippent
qui sont hyper valorisant ce moment là
il y en a la moitié dans qui va avoir
une carrière professionnelle
les uns les autres voire des ministres
des chéris de trois commotions
cérébrales et un beau rêve de jeunesse
qui vous dormez dans le fond de guerres
de rome alors que celui t'intéresse
allant peut-être qu'il ne deviendra pas
le prochain réjean ducharme un débat ou
pas mais il va pas travailler dans le
milieu d'édition il va peut-être publiés
dans des revues en tout cas ça va être
dans sa vie probablement plus longtemps
de façon plus professionnelle que peut
l'être laisse pas emporter jeunes
sportifs etc et investit pour qu'il
investit des centaines de milliers de
dollars parfois des millions c'est donc
un est non il ya une espèce de non sens
à ce pourquoi est ce que le sport est
ici développé alors que la littérature
la culture la science ne l'est pas et
moi sincèrement je peux me craint qu'ils
comptent les sportifs parce que c'est
hyper important du jeu explique dans ses
sauts pipi c'est un portable wii sa
structure la vie puis oui c'est des
souvenirs incroyables qui sur lesquels
on peut déployer notre personnalité
mais moi je crois qu'on peut en faire
autant sinon plus avec la littérature
les en plastiques les arts visuels
accuser la science la musique la musique
c'est quand même certaines écoles où
c'est vraiment développer ces
merveilleux moments ma fille dans une
école sacré 15 h r block yvan
spécialisée en musique puis je vois quel
point ça ça
alors saluons l'esprit puis bravo donc
au programme avec notre natation puis à
notre école y avait été et avait changé
avec théâtre avec guitare c'est des gens
qui prenaient tout l'après midi pour
aller faire pour les faire pas mal moins
que le choc quelques le sport c'est déjà
bien qu'ils aient fait douter les ovnis
sportif qui s'intéressent à leur mettons
ça sur une terrasse plus grands barrier
team où justement après le second
d'affaires des programmes soir et united
à musique peut acheter les titans
littérature fait quand on a des soucis
pis effectivement je suis vraiment
d'accord avec toi
l'at-il le sport par exemple - ne pas
avoir fait professionnellement
de padt après avoir poussé plus loin
c'est vraiment pas un regret pour moi
sens que ce que ça m'a apporté ce que ça
m'a appris
cette rigueur et discipline l'os et cet
investissement le ce désir de se
surpasser désir de s'améliorer de jour
en jour ça m'est resté
le juge m
et jamie d'amuser je les mets ici dans
d'autres contrats de créer dans ce
studio le fait que effectivement mais
c'est des leçons de vie 4-4 les sports
qui tue je pense que je pense que tout
est est intersectionnelle t à ce niveau
là j'ai lu haruki murakami cette année
six appels autoportrait de l'auteur en
coureur de fond je pense qu'on a entendu
parler lui dans le fond ici pour ceux
qui nous écoutent c'est un auteur
japonais super reconnu le pis il s'est
intéressé à la course à pied puis au
marathon pileux il réalisait que dans
son entraînement pour le marathon c'est
à dire à tous les jours is love
à 8 heures il va courir sont 15 km puis
un programme d'entraînement vraiment
strictes qui a réussi à transposer ce
dans son écriture avec un peu comme on
dit tout à l'heure le tir que tout tu
crois pas un an la page blanche qui lui
se mettaient des heures puis le matin il
y avait son cadran et un sa routine
clair puis l'oeil était devant sa page
puis une autre fois que je t'entends des
dit aussi que je trouve super
intéressant c'est l'écriture automatique
puis que si une devant sa page puis que
rien qui sort il que tout sera repéré
sur le paris puis fait lui y compris la
rigueur du sport pour le mettre dans
l'ordre c'est pas nécessairement une
adéquation qu'on fait automatiquement
n'étant qu'à qu'on pense à ce puits puis
je trouve que c'est un peu un bonbon
avec ce qu'on disait plutôt le tir de
comme essayer d'avoir une structure
aussi absolument basse et la haute sûre
qu'ils disaient la liberté c'est la
discipline à 14
c'est paradoxal mais c'est quand même un
carton discipline de travail de vie
sattouf plein d'autres libertés ça te
laisse du temps pour autre chose ça te
permet de ta complice et de te libérer
l'esprit de de ces projets dont sera
victime aussi triste mais j'en ai plein
le dd n'est très bon job un talent qui
est qu'ils veulent faire un album va le
faire relève alpha ben jaffar depuis
10-15 west ham et qui elle est exacte
voilà maintenant qui arrivent pas le
faire pour un paquet de raisons mais la
discipline
tonton roman tu arriveras pas avec un
roman de 300 pages sur lecointe attend
demain matin ça va être un goût de cinq
pages qui parfois tu vaux flash et 10
pages qui parfois tu vois de voir encore
g20 pendant trois semaines mais chaque
ligne que tu écris c'est un pas de plus
vers cet objectif
donc oui la discipline et oui la
question à ce parti va la limite là
dedans pied quelque chose de physique
même dans l'écriture à dany laferrière
est un écrivain d'après une chose qu'ils
doivent ainsi se trouver un bon fauteuil
parce que c'est donc travaillé dessus
puis sont fait un lien avec les auteurs
japonais battue a dit yukio mishima ce
qui était un obsédé de l'entraînement
l'image de sous et tout mais qui avait
aussi cette espèce de rigueur cette
discipline là et moi j'y crois je trouve
ya quelque chose d'admirable aussi là
dedans c'est oui tant mieux pour les
génies qui arrive avant des fulgurances
incroyable mais moi j'ai quand même plus
d'admiration pour l'artisan qui lève
chaque matin puis qui retravaille son
texte qui est le peaufiner qui vraiment
dans une discipline et rigueur
vauvert son bus vers son oeuvre au
quotidien
puis moi je me reconnais plus là dedans
puis c'est pas dans ce sens que je
trouve ma démarche admirable mais en ce
sens que c'est ce qui m'a inspiré chez
les autres et que j'essaie de faire à ma
manière cela touche laquelle un contrôle
aussi les riches glissement la réaction
du monde contrôlé non plus le génie du
je peux travailler avec ce que toi même
jusqu à dire qu est-il la discipline
puis même le sacrifice t'amène au
bonheur finalement le tir parce que ce
sentiment là de construire quelque chose
d'être approché de ton but de de terreur
de l'accomplissement personnel tu amènes
satisfaction beaucoup plus grande qu'une
satisfaction mais ton qui serait de
plaisir instantané qui se perd gratis
qui sépare le fun qui se pare d intenses
sur le coup mais que finalement c'est la
somme de tout ce finalement est beaucoup
plus destructeur que la rigueur la
discipline qui mène justement le
sacrifice pour après se tut tut tu
regardes tu parles pas de recul puis du
crime je me sens tellement mieux
tellement plus heureux dans ce cadre le
que dans est ce que tu avais à faire
mais oui c'est certain qu'on tient qu'au
niveau d'équilibré d'avoir des trucs
mais c'est vrai que ça tourne exemple si
je te met qu'un canton programme de
secondaire on a rejeté on s'entraînait
huit fois par semaine c'est à dire tous
les après midi de semaine trois matins
par semaine à 5h30 du matin
fakher ont passé c'est ce qui explique
tout et notamment de deux heures
faki émeutes ont cité en tout une
vingtaine d'heures d'entraînement le thé
intense pink sheets et aux jantes et
samedi matin ne peuvent pas veiller
vendredi soir à 6h et en piscine samedi
matin tc st les gens reviennent porte et
puis comment tu fais comment tu peux
avoir la discipline psicom premièrement
c'est un engrenage dans lequel quand tu
es dans finalement puis quand il fait
assez longtemps
ça devient le nord et élites se lever à
6 heures peut-être que tu as la peau dit
un jour je me lève à 6h pour écrire mais
quand ça devient ta vie ça devient de
plus en plus facile de le faire vous
savez même plaisir de faire puis
qu'at-il fait peut-être justement
quinconces élevé si on le dit plusieurs
fois ici mika que j'ai pas samedi matin
restez y est je me lève à cinq ans avant
d'entraîner pendant 12 ans pour moi sauf
qu'à l'achat sacrifice effective week
end par le step back
t l'action de me lever samedi matin par
le farceur ça me tente pas le serment
mais quand je prends cette époque je me
dis est ce que j'aime la vie que je mène
est ce que je suis bien là dans ce que
je suis heureux witi parce que ça
m'amène tellement plus que lesquels elle
est le sacrifice de faire l'action le
samedi matin seulement absolument puis c
c'est aussi l'idée de jaime était leur
côté coureurs de fond c'est dans le
temps si tu travailles fort pour une
plus grande récompense est la récompense
que tu vas te donne et qui voit qu'il va
vraiment donner ta dopamine et ou de
sortir le samedi soit rapide gère et
dont la même attaque
c'est une vraie satisfaction qui est qui
est là mais qui est peut-être moins
durable et qui surtout est quand même
moins méritoire qui te préparer pour une
compétition de natation ou de préparer
un livre ou un peu importe quel projet
dont et sait aussi qu est ce qui reste à
la fin de son fait lien que les ddd
relation ben j'ai l'impression que c'est
la relation à soi même
cc qu'est ce qui nous laisse à la fin
basse et comment on aurait été en
relation humaine avec les autres pièces
qu est ce qu on a reconstruit comme
entourage autour de nous mais aussi
comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir se
regarder soi même au bout de la route
dès ce que j'ai fait un peu ce que je
voulais faire ce que je me suis approché
de ce que je voulais à être puis surtout
est ce que j'ai mis les efforts pour
dresser son ultime ans parce que y'a
rien de grand ne se fait sans effort
puis le temps ne respecte pas ce qui se
fait sans lui donc il faut cimade stable
il faut que tu m'aides pas ça comme si
c'était juste une phrase d'un même qui
sait le temps ne respecte pas ce qui se
fait sans lui ce soit à gauche c'est à
pied mais c'est parce que c'est
tellement vrai
c'était sûr restera pas un obsédé des
citations qui dans la bataille parce que
je fais toujours des mauvais citation
sophie deux fois par la main qui est un
hommage à quelqu'un dans chacun des
romains mais ça me fait penser à un ami
dj avec qui j'ai fait du rap qu'acheter
adopte ce puits étaient des dj puis m'a
neigé disait s'attendre [ __ ] est décrite
si tu fais [ __ ] et expédie et kaufman je
connais tellement la musique j'ai
tellement ce que j'ai comme disque puis
comme chanson dans mais qu'est ce que
pour chaque émotion que je vis pour
chaque chose que j'ai envie d'exprimer
je peux prendre
l'album où la chanson c'est et mongin
pressage lit tellement maintenant ce que
j'ai fait que des citations j'en ai
plein ma pomme bat bien et tout que
souvent dans une situation comme ça et
[Rires]
là c'est la puissance des citations le
bateau quand tu es tu parlais justement
telle la discipline pourtant rapproché
quelque chose d'une question vous est
posée parce que tu es tout tout est un
homme de plusieurs métiers météo temps
la poésie que le roman que le slam que
la musique les mots en fait c'est un
jour la musique parce que
moi je compose pour moi c'est gbla j'ai
fait un album nouveau matériel ou bang
un peu chiante à peine soit un truc ou
deux des chansons rap ou plus
slam spoken word mais j'écris aussi pour
d'autres mais ce travail de parole et
d'écriture fait qu'ouis je donne
l'impression de faire plein d'affaires
mais potins tous deux finalement demain
des fois c'est moi qu'il dit sur sa
haine à radio pointe mois parfois cc
d'autres parfois je le publie mais c'est
vraiment l'écriture pensez vraiment les
mots qui accents à la base puis je
dirais que c'est l'étincelle que j'ai
réussi à garder de mon enfance c'était
merveille mans là quand j'ai réalisé
qu'avec juste 26 lettres je pouvais
faire vivre des émotions ignore ce
pouvait influencer sa passe et tu
pouvais comprendre des concepts
abstraits
pour moi il ya vraiment quelque chose
qui relève un peu de la du sacré et de
la magie dans l'écriture est là et la
lecture j'ai l'impression que c'est
quelque chose de magique mais on
maîtrise tellement bien la technique
qu'on oublie à quel point ces puces
entre les ponts voler un texte choquer
tout comme si de rien n'était mais je
viens de ces justes des symboles sur une
feuille
pis tu t'es mis en contact avec la
pensée quelqu'un d'autre avec lui
l'esprit de quelqu'un d'autre
pour moi ça reste encore intense et puis
je suis vraiment en apprentissage l'aqdr
l'impression que je sois mambo bout de
ce que j'ai à découvrir avec l'écriture
de la lecture mais parfois je m'arrête
jean core tier one
c'est génial pis ma fille aussi qui est
en première année menace aussi les crocs
sont des fois fait la poésie sans sarah
c'est magique est moins taxé que ce soit
une chronique ou une peau est moins
remercie finalement c'est le même geste
le soi même c'est le même geste mais pas
avec la
la même intention pas que le même élan
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose qui
s'est pas dans mes pompes du cerveau
tout en touche je disais la poésie
pousser plus loin ses râles puis il ya
plusieurs façons de faire la poésie - de
la façon je les fais ça reste quand même
accessible c'est pas très hermétique
mais c'est quand même une forme qui est
un peu plus d'ambiguïté qui est un peu
plus dans dans l'émotion dans le dire
vrai que le roman ou pour moi c'est
vraiment un jeu la chronique ou
j'interpelle mais ce genre fait beaucoup
moins bien il ya une fatigue qui ne vous
donner l'opinion ne juge jamais
travaillé livre que je fais moins de
chronique d'opinion mais à travers aussi
le travail de paroliers quand j'écris
pour d'autres des fois j'écris des
chansons sans trop savoir où ça va aller
mais quand je laissais expérience
incroyable s'écrit pour florence que
reste il faut par exemple c'est
tranquille ça va être une grande voix ça
va être chantées pauvres et les
mouvements qui va le pousser
c'est pas du tout la même culture que
pour un mythe ex amants que je vais
publier et d'ailleurs je trouve qu'on se
sous-estiment le travail des interprètes
dont j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour les
interprètes puis tant mieux pour les
auteurs compositeurs qui interprètent
leur propre matériel
mais même celles et ceux qui
interprètent la menthe et rien d autre
qu une forme d'art et croyant prendre un
texte n'est pas le tien est elle
appropriée puis le faire vivre le faire
raisonner autrement il ya tout une
question de jurado dévoilement de soi à
travers à l'intonation et et monstres un
grand grand plaisir 15 j'offre un texte
où quelqu'un me demandant le texte qu
après jonathan vivent même ça m'est
arrivé de ne pas reconnaître mon temps
est ce que c'était pas l'intention
vraiment écrivain je l'entendais de
façon très ballan très introspectif le
final bassesse et chanter de façon la
plus intense puissante épée que la
limite ça va mais pas question la
validité mettons artistique
d'interprètes de théâtre ma tante et des
docteurs versus chanteur interprète
condat à bâtir une politique pour
amasser thoune
c'est beau c'est drôle s'essaye à ces
deux poids deux mesures exactement et
personne qui va les remettre en question
le talent un des menus schwarz anne
marie cadieux point pas parce que ce
sont de grands interprètes et qu'on
reconnaît l'arbre qui se déploie
peut-être aussi tu pendant une heure
dans l'ennemi c'est yaya il dire quelque
chose dans la performance
alors que un interprète son art consommé
par chanson c'est à moi d'aller voir en
spectacle et de l'aimer des jeux un
interprète dans l'auto trois minutes
comme une petite capsule donc parfois ça
va être évident que c'est évident que
c'est plus ça on peut ne pas être fan de
céline dion mais aucun cas se donne
alors que que d'autres qu'on va entendre
à la radio
parfois on se repasse et je pense
attentif aux jeux de l'interprétation
puis c'est important tout en laye tu
parlais tantôt je voulais je voulais
revenir là dessus parce que c'est
quelque chose que je voulais aborder que
toi de revendiquer le droit à la fiction
puis j'ai lu
tam en a moins dernièrement du bain
dernière fin de semaine puis c'est très
dernièrement s'est dernièrement
si ça c'est c'est la chose qui m'a
fasciné dans leurs mains c'est de
prendre un code qui est super commun de
nos jours c'est à dire la biographie
puis de d'amener l'aspect fictionnel
sent vraiment seul exposé clairement au
juste en utilisant toutes les codes
qu'on connaît déjà mais juste de faire
quelque chose de complètement fictionnel
ancré dans le réel puis de naviguer
cette fine line glottis moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours fasciné
puis j'avais l'impression quand je
lisais ton romain de de lire
limonov d'emmanuel carrère mais en fait
en fait il apparaît n'entendant ton dans
ton roman puis qu'elle est apparue si le
que j'ai fait sa route est un hommage
parce que j'imaginais un extraterrestre
mettons qui arrive qui arrive sa planète
puis qui connaît pas l'histoire retient
qu'il y mettons limonov et kylie tamara
mois puis possiblement que l'impression
que limonov est aussi réelle que marie
maude cette espèce de naviguer entre le
réel et la fiction
je trouve ça super je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant d'un point de vue de
lecteurs ça c'est quelque chose que toi
consciemment mettons tu t'es tu disais
que tu allais faire est ce que ces
caisses qui se créent le qu'est-ce qui
le processus créatif de faire cesser
d'en créer une fiction dans le réel
c'est le pur désir de jouer avec la
forme point vraiment très heureux que ce
soit ce terreau tenu à souligner parce
que pour moi c'est la grande originalité
de ce roman le centre et se reposer une
fausse biographie mais un moment très
précis dans le fond on comprend que on a
accès au manuscrit d'un biographe avec
toutes ses notes ses réflexions au
moment où il va décider s'ils publient
ou pau n'ont pas pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
vont publier au poids quel point est
impliqué donc c'est lé cette idée
d'allouer avec une travail formel
particulier au niveau de l'écriture dans
un moment particulier est effectivement
d'aller jouer avec les codes de la
biographie et il ya certaines personnes
derrière qui m'ont dit qu'ils ont google
mails montanes est le passe droit
d'exister pourrait en fait qu'un jet je
me préparais pour l'entrevue j'ai fait
ça aussi plus j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
liste de recherche préfète légal foyer
qu'elle le monde chercher sur google
fait que la limo glisse-t-elle c'était
marimo de biographies marie-maude amamou
l'est et kayes est tout sauf de la
guerre le personnage transcender le
livre c'est une fausse page wikipédia
vraiment écrit leur faut facebook un
fouet pour moi c'est un peu comme par
rapport aux séries outardes porte fois
que la femme ait écrit je laisser vivre
mais si quelqu'un le projet mais oui fx
en mai mais oui c'était vraiment
un travailleur au niveau de la forme
puis emmanuel carrère je trouve ce soit
intéressant fait sa démarche lui il ya
fait de la fiction et commencer je pense
cinq romans vraiment de fiction puis
après il est tombé dans des romans de
non fiction à s'inspirer beaucoup de sa
vie où se révèlent beaucoup puis sa
démarche est intéressante et
m'interpelle
j'ai un projet un peu plus précis
éventuellement je pense que je le fais à
travers mon spectacle au bout de ta
langue je raconte vraiment plus mon
rapport personnel à la littérature mais
au niveau de l'écrit mouche encore plus
intéressés par la fiction
même si parfois faut jouer justement
avec les limites qu est-ce qui
appartient à la fiction qu'est-ce qui
est parti on pensait du personnage
lesquels sont les miennes et dans tamara
- ya beaucoup des réflexions du
biographe qui qui qui sont les miennes
en trop celle sur la littérature celle
sur l'appropriation culturelle qui
marque tout mon percement biographe
prend position
parfois je le pousse un peu loin pour
faire réagir les lecteurs mais c'est
quand même des réflexions un que j et si
houellebecq que j'aime bien aussi c'est
qu'ils disaient de toutes les formes
dansées par la littérature qu'on rentre
le plus en contact avec l'artiste parce
qu'on est vraiment vraiment que ça ça
passe et je trouve que ça s'applique
même aux fictions parce que rêver c'est
la bête c'est pas moins mais en lisant
la bête je comprends qu'elle jean dumont
j'apprécie oui contrat commenge
structure même à penser au niveau
syntaxique ça donne accès à un humain et
puis c'est une raison pour lesquelles
moins communs comme lecteurs souvent je
vais lire tout un auteur toutes nos
tristes quand je les découvre puis
l'idéal c'est qu'en ce moment parce que
le thème pas besoin d'attendre qui
s'offrent au complet dans notre logique
sinon faut que pratiquer ta patience
mais mais je trouve ça intéressant
d'entrer en contact avec l'esprit d'un
écrivain d'une écrivaine et je respecte
ce qui se ne se cache pas mais se place
derrière la fiction et je suis de ceux
là où il ya des bouts de moi que je
révèle jusqu'en même jean personnages
publics truqués qui médiatisé mais je ne
révèle pas tous qui est en repos d'infos
souvent sur mes enfants que je protège
mes mais parfois je vais donner quand
même des indices plus personnelle ou
autre genre l'impression a révélé à
travers des personnages fictifs parfois
paradis tu as parfois de façon frontale
mais mais c'est la force des
littératures aussi de jouer sur cette
ambiguïté de l'affairé jusqu'au y pense
kiss kiss qui écrit à quel point
s'apprête à mons à quel point anne
hébert romancière et poète d'une
sensibilité incroyants quant à marseille
dans le meurtre en gaspésie à quel point
ces fantasmes ou par aucune idée et une
question tu poses dans ta mort à moi qui
est la question
juste un bon segway avec jusque sur la
question de la mort de l'auteur puis une
fois que l'heure des sorties de l'auteur
est-ce qu'on peut encore lié
est-ce qu'on peut encore consommé
l'oeuvre en ne prenant pas compte de
l'auteur de la ville hôte orpi c'est une
question qui dernièrement se pose pour
vous dans plusieurs sphères artistiques
on est juste à penser à woody allen
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec son oeuvre ben
moi le problème en fait c'est justement
ce que ça se pose dans la sphère
artistique
c'est ce que j'ai amené dans le livre
qui je pense était mené une réflexion on
le sent bien quand même étrange
peut-être mais original quand même
est ce qu'on consomme quand même le
recueil de maryvonne malgré ce que le
score est sec et l'est où quelques lots
pure fm et de façon très concrète en
fait mouche suis dérangé par exemple
park en salle culturelle compagnie je
suis d'accord qu'il ya des sentences
judiciaire qui a lieu lacan qui est
notre homme public aussi dans certains
cas mais quand on décide de ne plus
consommer l'oeuvre d'un artiste
on est aussi en train de dire que l'anrs
moindre valeur que tous les autres
champs d'expertisé dans la vie pythagore
même s'il était pédophile son théorème
célèbre fonctionne pas si le corbusier
est agréé sentirait pas démolir ces
bâtiments sous prétexte que c'est un
architecte qui ont qu'on ne peut plus
consommer quand moi je convaincu que
michael jackson c'était un être ignoble
dans certains de ses comportements
qu'ils étaient profondément dérangé mais
d'un point de vue objectif beat it
c'est une bonne touche si schild et
sachant que plus tard qu'il avait tant
de morts sur coup quitte à la maison
puis les petits coquins
voilà mais je peux faire le choix de ne
pas acheter l'oeuvre surtout d'un
artiste vivant est marqué la lumière se
voit priver sa descendance de ses droits
alors que wii est un génie musical
derrière et même la question se pose
c'est si la personne commis des gestes
inacceptables
quelque part au milieu de sa carrière
est ce que on peut consommer ces
premières heures alors que c'est un
humain acceptable où il faut tout mettre
aux vidanges et c'est vraiment solide et
c est ce que l art à une réelle valeur
objective pour moi oui il ya une valeur
artistique comme une valeur
mathématiques et on ne peut pas renier
l'oeuvre on peut condamner l'artiste de
plein de façons condamner la personne
mais pour moi il faut quand même laisser
vivre les oeuvres voilà la question se
pose quand même si l'artiste encore
vivants comme tu mentionnes tiennent
maintenant émettons
louis siquet si on écoute on sait
special en ce moment qu'il tournait
avant de se faire dénoncer et tout
l'argent lui revient quand même ça c'est
un choix qui pour moi est appartient à
chacun et que je peux tout à fait
comprendre que c'est correct mais je ne
peux pas dire que l'os et qui est un
imbécile sans talent ni aucune qualité
que toute sa vie doit être condamné tu
vois je trouve que c'est vraiment serré
entre personnels comme question seppi
puis en fait c est ce que ce que tu sais
sur l'auteur tente ton appréciation de
l'oeuvre parce que sa teinte cette
autorisation point que de plaisirs
métier moi tu vois exactement ce qui
était dit
cette petite la même comme quelque chose
d'hallucinant pages qui est moi mettons
jeu capable j'ai beaucoup plaisir à
écouter jackson five
mais j'ai pris des mesures actives
michael jackson triggs parce que tu sais
pas si choqué d'affaires comme geste et
7 heures
ouais tu y mets ton j'ai entendu j'ai
posté je suppose ça me met hors de moi
sauf que sauf que sa tante mon
appréciation petit qu'un qu'une tonne
joue bas j'y pense je pense pas que chez
- j'ai moins le goût de me déhancher
sous bill est le sais parce que je suis
absolument d'accord avec toi puis choix
reste je peux le vivre avec certaines
vont parler de woody allen
oui effectivement dernièrement j'ai vu
un film de woody allen qui est quoi qui
me fait skate ou tout le long mais dans
le fond parce que ce que je veux dire
c'est que on ne peut pas mettre aux
oubliettes un peu poète son régime
soviétique qui règne dans ce cas les
très bons éléments pour reconnaître que
ça existait faut reconnaître que le y
avait un certain talent faut reconnaître
que ç'a influencé aussi l'on peut
prendre que l'on dutronc reprendre
pleinement diluée ya des gens qui ont pu
être axe absolument condamnable dans
leurs actions mais que leurs oeuvres
artistiques et significative quand même
et elle existe et on peut faire le choix
de ne pas la consommer exact puisque
hier la limite le mouvement est légitime
moi ce que ce que je dis c'est jean
marais ce cas ça va trop loin et qu'on
doit à la lime et nier l'existence ou ne
plus l'étudier ne plus regarder si j'ai
étudié en cinéma
je devrais être exposé à mener à ce que
claude je te refais puis je devrai aussi
est informé des gestes qu'on lui
reproche qui après je ferai mon choix
est ce que j'accepte d'être influencé au
pop art sommet c'est la négation absolue
moi qui suis d'accord avec ce type
justement d'adam sous le petit pc
personnel sepideh comment que moi je
réagis à tes lèvres ça chanceux c'est
moi je pense qu on peut tout à fait
comme un individu décidé de ne plus
consommer 6e mais je pense pas qu'on
peut l'imposer aux autres qu'on peut
l'imposer à aux études universitaires
qu'on petit je pense pas que ce sens mal
qui personnel devrait on devrait entre
l'imposer comme n'est comme une vérité
que jacques delors règle mes règles
c'est exactement
ouais c'est intéressant c'est vraiment
une question tu dit tantôt que y avait
une très bonne fatigue face à l'opinion
puis ce j'imagine que j'imagine que tout
le monde la ressent un peu le tir espèce
d'ovni plastique d'abord d'opinion
moi personnellement je suis tanné de
l'opinion en général puis de la
d'omniprésence de l'opinion de tous sur
la place publique pis quand on parle
d'un choix personnel comme celui là
je trouve que je trouve qu'il ya trop
d'emphase sur le pignon d'une personne
ou de quelques personnes qui dictent
c'est un peu la façon de penser de
quelqu'un qui se poserait pas la
question profondément maintenant l'outil
puis est ce que c'est quelque chose que
toi
en fait qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui est
à la source de cette de la fatigue de
l'opinion que quelqu'un était m en fait
c'est assez les et court je pense que
les opinions au lieu d'être je pense que
c'est bien qu'on les entende
par contre c'est que c'est une espèce de
d'onde qui se répercute longtemps pour
pour tout ce qui est vécu de façon
sociale pour tous qui partageait c'est à
dire que moi j'aime avoir des opinions
d'un côté puis de l'autre
j'ai un peu orphelin politique aussi gtd
parfois je pense plutôt au centre gauche
mais je me suis dit je considérais pas
mal plus à gauche que ça me manque et je
me reconnais - la dame je pas droit non
plus mais il y à droite et pas juste des
imbéciles lui historiquement est la
gauche de grandes grandes errance puis
il ya des erreurs se sont fait aussi
dans g c'est vraiment de me faire une
tête sur sur tout ce qui ce qui nous
concerne comme société et de considérer
les opinions à gauche à droite par qu'on
est au centre
par contre ce qui se passe c'est que des
deux côtés
une fois que l'opinion et hemmings
beloeil des radios parlait à temps plein
qui vont reprendre ce devant leurs
manches et il ya de la nouvelle à temps
plein qui volent leurs manches et qui va
chercher du vox pop qui vont ils
chercher des gens qui ont vraiment pas
d' expertise mais qui vont me crier
encore me répéter le pignon d'intel
relais pneu loeb en pis j'ai
l'impression que on n'a pas le temps de
laisser mijoter on n'a pas le temps de
laisser s'enraciner à ces informations
là et de ceux construits sont appuyés on
est toujours dans tout restants pensent
tous réagi
j'ai en 12 heures exactement puis c'est
pas deux minutes qui n'étaient pas avec
nous dès contre nous en fait ce ton le
kia qui me dérange davantage puis
l'espèce des faits vraiment soutenu en
fait d'être bombardé puis à plein plein
de niveaux sur plein de sujets puis des
choses super important des changements
de fond de la société que c'est qu'avec
ce soit présent mais présente tout le
temps aux intenses et parfois sur des
choses insignifiantes ou des trucs qui
qui me concerne pas mais que le jeu
quand le troisième-ligne québec le car
est plus beau plus d'actualité ok on va
prendre position s'exprimer là dessus
mais on va revenir vous fait le point
ça c'est l'impression qu'on qu'on a
revient peau de rien c'est comment naît
faut accepter puis parfois même si
inconfortable des changements sociaux
peut-être et clickair je vous adresse
mes acquis adhérents du loupé c'est
correct je vais marquer mais faut pas
trop étirer sa carotte aux manettes de
forcer d'abord comme de l'autre
j'ai l'impression que plutôt que dans
des débats d'idées plutôt que d'en de
l'information plutôt que dans des
reportages de fond on est dans martelé
son opinion le plus possible sur le plus
de plateformes possibles pour essayer
d'influencer et j'ai l'impression que
comme citoyen moi ça crée une tension
perpétuelle
puis j'ai juste envie que charles
tisseyre amans soult que quelqu'un m'a
dit qui regarde on va y aller au fond de
la patente longtemps jaser pendant deux
ans et après tu en pense et ce que tu
voudras muto que effectivement parler du
téléphone d'être interpellé mais plutôt
que d'être peu épuisé d'avoir un ami qui
complètement braqué d'un côté puis un
ami qui est complètement braqué de
l'autre qui bombarde statut que c'est
plus cela la fatigue c'est soif
d'information et de reportages de fond
en versus l'opinion répéter martelé
peut-il de par leur nature une opinion
et du moment que tu étais à prononcer
automatiquement un terrain glissant
parce que c'était forcément toujours
quelqu'un qui n'ait pignon en désaccord
ou contraire la tienne seppi j'ai
l'impression que nous beaucoup de
difficultés de plus en plus de
difficultés à entendre puis à débattre
avec des opinions qui sont différentes
de la nôtre le tpiy n'a connu que la
réponse au lieu que la discussion soit
de bonne foi tu qu'on essaie de tir de
discuter pour essayer de qui émerge à
l'irt et c'est comme un dîner pignon
quelques jeux pas d'accord d'infos qp il
ça fait que je sais ce cas-là débit
finalement on n'est pas en train
d'avancer régler en train de comme
s'enfoncer financer la différence
atteint encore bob des bottes
j'ai l'impression qu'on est beaucoup
plus en mode combat qu'en mode des
bonnes mamans les médias qu'on utilise
encourage sow citifx à fait évident que
l'ex a fait réagir puis aussi faisait au
québec ont au moins la culture du des
bocks qu'en europe par exemple alors que
c'est c'est hyper intéressant puis mots
j'aime qu'on qu'on fasse changer d'idée
par moments teach peu tête de cochon
pénalités 10 x mon opinion si je vais
m'en porte et je vais tenir
mais qu'est ce qu'elle la réflexion est
à mener de façon un peu documentée pour
documenter ou en tout cas au delà de
l'émotion c'est ce n'est pas faux faut
parfois sortir de les motifs qui rendent
ses lettres de noblesse dont seulement à
la science et la sociologie est une
science la psychologie aussi et essayer
d'aller à creuser un peu plus loin
justement que la spontanéité de
l'émotion de la prise de parti et du
combo est absolument parce que justement
d'après ses combos l'oeil
finalement la vérité un musée lablée
quantifiable et objective le typhon ont
finalement on des bottillons ont même on
s'engueule sur des idées tant qu en
réalité existe
quelque part une réponse asymétrique
qu'on pourrait par la science ou par
différentes méthodes accéder le dernier
mot est souvent un chiffre chercher
l'information précise pas ses saucisses
facile de dire on est envahi des
migrants ou lé recul du français
n'existent pas enfin papier jaune est
une pierre cardin objectivement c'est
quoi le constat est exact de juste
apprendre les les façons d'aller
chercher c'est quoi la méthodologie
scientifique aussi des des statistiques
parce que ma foi on va utiliser des
chefs pour nourrir les motions or l
opinion assez voilà il ya vraiment
quelque chose de particulier je pense à
notre époque mais qu'on va prendre
moi je suis assez confiant qu'on convoi
réagir comme société à l'échelle même
planète 1 puis qu'on va retrouver un
équilibre un moment donné entre la
discussion le débat et la science
parce qu'en ce moment tout le monde j'ai
près sur ma fatigue pour tout le monde
mais ma fête et du partage
j'adore il va falloir retourner dans
damon plus efficaces de communication
on se reconnaît pas trop fort pour moi
je me reconnais pas dans ta fatigue
aussi
qui disait ça mais que tout artiste doit
pas être engagée est ce que c'est
quelque chose comme en mai
mais ça c'est dit quelque chose
mettons-le alors juste peut exister à
l'extérieur la société c'est quelque
chose que toi auquel tu crois absolument
ouais souvent gage et je pense que mon
parcours travailleur social
ils jouent pour beaucoup on interpelle
parfois pour des causes auxquelles je
crois donc je me retrouve forcément peut
être là la caisse qui est engagée mais
je fais aussi des oeuvres qui qui ne le
sont pas ou qui n'ont pas cette fonction
première
un d'ailleurs un tj tient les romances
peau des vignettes clinique de
travailleur social de romancier puis si
à travers bien des questions sociales
qui émergent qui viennent te questionner
tant mieux mais la fonction première
c'est à être d'oeuvres d'art et l'or se
suffit leur suffit parfois justement tu
es au delà du message mouche très
heureux quand je vais au musée pickeu
une oeuvre abstraite vient choquer ou me
faire ressentir quelque chose d'un peu
plus subtil que l'émerveillement où la
révolte ou donc l'expérience humaine par
l'or est suffisante
ici un message derrière qui transforma
pensée qui me permet de changer la
société tant mieux mais non l'artiste
nos poètes engagés à tout prix ces
supports est si fascinant je parlerai
encore des heures
ben je viens à rire et des autres soient
certains que chez vous vous cachez vous
voulez avant
avant de laisser partir qu'est ce qui
s'en vient pour toi ou est-ce que les
gens qu'est ce que les gens peuvent
faire pour te suivre pour t'encourager
c'est que les projets sur lesquels tu
travaille présentement ben moi j'ai
envie si ce n'est fait d'être curieux
par rapport à l'album le nouveau
matériel
c'est vraiment mon groupe rejet des
dernières années ça fait trois ans qu'on
travaille là-dessus
coproduit coréalisé avec manu militari
plein de belles collaborations de mafate
où j'ai encore bien c'est et fleurance
que le studio est ce que je pourrais
même l idée ses patins des deux artistes
que de dire non seulement ça c'est des
amis mais je vais faire un travail
d'équipé là dessus je me suis associé à
des gens que j'apprécie a déjà des airs
de grand talent et je suis vraiment fier
du résultat
je pense j'ai mis plusieurs demi
meilleurs textes des dernières années
sur ce projet l'eau et j'ai envie que ça
ça résonne que les gens l'écoutent de
façon très intime
j'ai envie que le déposant les oreilles
je serai pas de spectacle que cet album
là c'est vraiment un projet un studio
donc c'est le gros morceau le kiki sur
la table en ce moment puis sinon ce qui
s'en vient mais je reprends la tournée
avec eux au bout de talent il me restait
un an tournée donc long art déplacer à
déplacer les spectacles je me promenais
avec ça dans l'année qui vient
puis s nom d'un livre jeunesse sur la
séparation qui vous sortir au mois
d'avril s'appelle la réparation mes
parents et je pense cependant ce qu'est
ce que je repars sur une autre question
dernière question est ce que parce qu'il
est clair maintenant on t'en passer de
travailleur social nourri ton oeuvre en
fait
puis est ce que tu veux continuer à agir
comme travailleur social pour continuer
à sur le terre
et rencontrer des gens je le fais depuis
cinq ans moins un jour que je suis
vraiment artiste à temps plein ce que tu
sens que c'est quelque chose qui manque
non parce que je le fais quand même
c'est quand je vais rencontrer des
détenus ou un des gens qui ont des
troubles de santé mentale les organismes
non tape un palais madame c'est le coin
de la rue aussi mais bien quand même du
travail social à travers ce j'ai
l'impression je raisonne autrement si le
lien directement dans le bus roulent
côté clinique peu manqué par moments
mais mais pas tellement parce que à la
base il est artiste j'ai fait un beau
détour par le travail social passe a
nourri mon oeuvre
mais maintenant si je voulais être
écrivain à 8 ans pire je suis heureux de
l'état 40
j'ai pas envie de changer ça mais mais
j'ai l'impression que c'était le des
taux parfait pour moi pour trouver ma
couleur comme artiste puis néron peut
concrétiser ma vision du monde et à
pouvoir la mettre en mots après donc non
je n'ai je pas mal sur mon x en ce
moment restait à les pieds dessus le
plus longtemps possible le souhaitent